what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 18th
of [__] august the joint is
brought to you by blue chew
listen blue chew is [__] tremendous
blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis only at a fraction of
the cost you could take at any time
day and night and the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com and talk to one
of the licensed medical providers once
you're approved you receive the
prescription within days the best part
of it it's all online
no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations and no waiting
online at the pharmacy not getting brow
beated you know the [__] deal and it
comes in a package and nobody knows
what's in there not even the mailman so
do me a favor if you could benefit from
a little extra confidence
when it's time to perform blue chew can
help if you want to [__] up that [__]
and it looks like the [__] wolf man
when you get through with it go to blue
chute
right now dot com promo code joey to
receive your first month of blue chew
for free you like joey what are you
talking about it's wednesday what's free
free
bluetooth.com promo code joey just pay
five dollars for shipping and bluechu
will turn you on
to one of the best
online services that you could deal with
you understand me like i said you could
take it any time
day and night and get ready to sling
some big dick with blue chew
i'm talking she's gonna call you the
next day and go what the [__] were you
drinking last night you [__] me to
death last night i can't even go to work
today not even on zoom that's
bluechu.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month for free it's just five dollars
for shipping the joint is also brought
to you by upstart do you feel look
looking at your credit card statement
every month when you're in debt it can
feel like it never ends upstart can help
upstart is a fast easy way to get a
personal loan to pay off your debt
listen it's tough right now if you have
debt nobody's going to help you your
family is tapped everybody's tapped
whether it's paying off credit cards or
consolidating your debt get a simple
fixed monthly payment over 1 million
people have used upstart to get out of
debt so do me a favor find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com
joey i know things are rough and
upstart's there for you that's
upstart.com joey don't forget to use our
url to let them know i sent you and i
got to throw this in for the disclaimer
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application and now go to upstart.com
joey and get out of debt today go to
upstart.com
joey and don't forget to use the url to
let them know i sent you the joint is
also brought to you by cbd lion
everybody's talking about cbd but nobody
knows where to start you start with the
line go to cbdline.com right now
read the third party lab results read
about how cbd line will match you up
like let's say you got a bad elbow a
tennis elbow
look it up on cbd line now the chart of
what
cbd you're looking to get whether it's
the extra strength unscented l cbd
lotion the gummies with melatonin the
hemp flour the bath balls
if you need it cbd line has it they even
have a great
tape that you can put on your shoulder
little pieces of tape for your knee i
use them all the time they bail me out
of the surgery so do me a favor go to
cbdline.com right now
pressing code joey and get 20 off your
first order at
cbdlion.com let's get this [__]
party started it's wednesday and it's a
beautiful [__] day to be alive
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
we're here for another fun-filled joint
on wednesday the 18th
it's a beautiful [__] day
tomorrow i'll be in new jersey for a
[__] year
we're going to celebrate i don't know
what me and the wife at all we're going
to a movie at the wreck tomorrow night
with the kids [__] the lawn chairs
the whole [__] thing on thursday
like two [__] jerk-offs three
jerk-offs and then friday
we're going to the [__] uh
the pep rally holy [__] there's food
trucks there's a band
there's arts and crafts you know the
family [__] we're here this today to
talk about women
and [__] comedy you know
for years people make [__] remarks
about women doing comedy the guy from
letterman a couple years ago got fired
because he said there was no funny women
i beg to differ
i think there's like listen here's the
[__] statement that has always killed
me
when you say women aren't funny you
[__] contradict yourself right off
the bat
because we all grew up on lucille ball
lucille ball made his [__] scream for
years i don't see how i love lucy on tv
no more so makes you forget i love lucy
cracked us up when we were [__] kids
so for you to say somebody's not funny a
woman a man whatever
but we're just focusing on women i grew
up on lucille ball so i had tons of
[__] respect for them and i loved
that lady that died years ago god
blessed us all i forget what her name is
she was filthy and
i remember watching her host
[__] uh
the tonight show she would host for
johnny carson
and one night she had [__]
vanity on there
and she was saying that [__] she
started torturing vanity for you guys
who don't know vanity is a singer
that used to date prince and she made a
song called nasty girl i played it on my
patreon a couple weeks ago people were
like who the [__] is this it's an old
song from 1982.
and uh she was on the tonight show she
had gotten a little heat for dayton
prince or whatever
she's on the [__] tonight show and
the lady said too i can't believe you
dave prince
uh he makes michael jackson look like a
green beret and all this [__] i mean she
was [__] cracked you know this prince
had not really
prince had hit it was like 84 85 he had
hit but [__] didn't really know
who the [__] prince was you know
but anyway i i just liked her
and then when i moved to la when you go
to the comedy store there was a [__]
bunch of funny women
and you know
listen i had a hard time following guys
at the store
but let me tell you something one of the
hardest [__] follows
at that store was a lady what the [__]
was her name it was just in the tip of
my tongue
was a lady from houston texas that used
to run with kennison and bill hicks and
carla beau
she came to one of my shows in
connecticut beaumont bacon was her name
holy [__]
let me tell you something when beaumont
bacon went on a [__] roll if you had
a follower and you were a man you were
dead
you were dead
and i tried to warn guys about her like
i'm like dog
you're following bowman bacon on a
saturday night you don't want no piece
of that
and they would say [__] you i'm at the
store every night i can follow anybody
okay
listen it
it didn't [__] i knew i knew better
i'm the type of dude that i [__] see
the dangers and i try to avoid them if
you gotta [__] you know jump into the
lion's mouth you jump into the lion's
mouth with [__] two hands and your
dick out but
you know
you i know what's dangerous you know
what i'm saying obviously i you know
when something's dangerous i [__]
stay the [__] away from it you know i
don't [__] with it i loved beaumont i
loved in fact she came to my show in
connecticut a couple of years ago to
thank me
for talking about her and for respecting
as much as i did
i remember i went to la jolla i had to
do a gig in san diego and i stopped at
la jolla and there was a comic there no
names
and i
i
went to visit him he was a good guy a
friend of mine
and i stopped by his show
before
my show my show was like a nine o'clock
show and he had a
a seven he had us an eight o'clock show
so i took him out to dinner at seven
and he was telling me like kind of
telling me because i had to follow a
beaumont last night and i'm like look
dog listen
i gave him a [__] fair warning i said
listen
we all want to be [__] great comics i
got no
problems with that but there's certain
people that you follow that you have to
work harder than others
you know
if she told them because he was saying
he was mad because
beaumont was a [__] headliner
and he was a headliner
kinda
and
they he kept saying well we're gonna
alternate
and i said to him listen
so she's gonna close out the first show
and he goes no no no no she's gonna
close out the second shot go listen bro
you don't want her to close out
you don't want to close out the first
show
that's the [__] date show
that's when decent people come and they
pay a babysitter and they [__] laugh
and guess what those are the same people
that go to comedy every week and they
see three man shows
they're gonna see a [__] girl and
women are gonna go nuts i go you don't
wanna especially in la jolla i go you
don't wanna follow her just tell her
you'll take the your feature for the
first show that's a smart move
and then the second show you go buck
wild because the audience is buck wild
you have nothing to lose he's like nah
that's [__] [__] i'm gonna follow the
first show listen
if you don't think i stayed to watch the
[__] disaster
you obviously don't [__] know me i'm
the type of dude that
i gotta see it to believe it so
i didn't say anything to him i tried to
[__] warn him
that women were dangerous in comedy he's
like nah
i could follow anybody at the store
i could follow beaumont bacon with my
eyes closed listen i called the promoter
and said there was traffic in l.a that
i'll be there like at 9 15. i usually
don't go on those shows till 9 40. i was
the headline of those days
i wasn't a headliner either let's get
that out of the way that was a long time
ago this had to be like
2 000.
i wasn't really a good headliner either
i was i was a [__] uh a good feature
act
and i'll never forget
we walked back from the chinese
restaurant i walked in there with him
and sure enough i gave bulman a hug i
giggled when i hugged you one of those
like the one that the butler gave eddie
murphy and boomerang when he brought the
[__] dish when he was at the old lady
when he had to [__] the old lady she
would invite people over and then [__]
him
that's the way i went up to and i kind
of giggled i'm like oh you're going to
kill this poor bastard she's like what
are you talking about
and i just sat there and i watched her
go up as a feature
for 20 minutes and this is what i'm
saying to you guys
like a guy like me
i'm dangerous in a 20-minute setting or
i was dangerous in a 20-minute setting i
know you guys heard it a thousand times
because i would take 45 minutes and
shrink it into 20 and not stop
it's it's it's my world i don't want to
do an hour our comments sucks
i'd rather do 20 minutes and blow you
out of the [__] water that you sit
there going what the [__]
is this [__] especially at the store at
the store i had those 18 minutes down to
a science i know that you'll hear people
going you got to follow joey at the
store whitney cummings always talks
about it
the hardest people i ever had to follow
was aj jamal
and then in the second chapter of my
comedy career there was one guy that was
dangerous in there and that was
crystalia crystalia allie wong was
[__] dangerous as death in the
original room and i made it my point to
follow ali wong i told
[__] adam eager i go listen
me and ally work perfect together
she [__] gets them open and i'll
[__] close them she knows exactly how
to open up my doors for me i love dally
wong because ali wong would leave me
with a tag to open up
that wasn't part of my act
listen when you go up i'm going to give
the comics a little tip right now when
you go up on stage
you don't want to open up with your
material
you want to open up with something that
just happened in the room you know i'm
saying that's how you really get them
and then you go into your written
material but you want to get them with
something loose for example
like allie wong would have a bit about
going up on stage uh
that she wanted to date a comic
but the comic had to be funnier than her
and for the comic to be funnier than her
meant that the comic had to be older
than she was
so you know
by the way she's talking about old men i
mean ali is probably 32 33 she's
beautiful i love her that great [__]
comic great lady i'm not saying nothing
bad about it but she would go you know
but she was she was r-rated ali wong
so she would talk all this [__] up there
about sex and stuff
and she would say you know i want
somebody to suck my [__] and all that
whatever
as soon as ali would bring me up
i would always go let's keep it going
for ali wong i would suck the yin yang
juice out of her [__] when you say yin
ying juice they go [__] nuts you
can't say it now because chinese people
get mad at you you know it's a joke i
would say it on stage
i would say that and bring the [__]
house down then i could slip into my
material then scott jeff scott would
play that song for me by uh
not calling the gang but the other band
do it to you satisfied whatever it is so
i would do a little wiggle and then i
would lay the line out about ali wong
and i would do that all together so now
it was like a free ride once you get
them with that yin yang juice you just
step roll them now you don't stop you
don't look back you don't look at your
notes you just go and that was my secret
you just go keep talking talk talk
don't even give them a chance to
laugh i wouldn't even give them a chance
to laugh that that applause break i
would just keep hammering them hammer
them hammer them for 18 minutes
i would leave there they would go what
the [__] was that that's the magic of
the store you learn at the store how to
use
those 18 minutes but anyway forget about
all the funniness and [__]
women in comedy have always
been a part of me
uh
last year when
people were like you know joe rogan
laughed at him talking about getting his
dick sucked if you see all the woman
that stick up for me a bunch of comics
female comics stuck up to me why
because i did pull them aside and i did
talk to them and i did give him love and
i did show him you know don't do there
was a girl that stuck up for me that
i'll never forget she's beautiful she
was a young girl we were in the main
room
and i saw that she had a shirt and she
was showing her tits
and i had seen her for like three
tuesdays in a row
and i really wanted to say something to
her but i didn't want to disrespect her
so finally one night she came up to me
she was a real cute girl real sweet i
don't know what her name was she'll tell
you when she hears the podcast she'll
pick up a hand and go he's talking about
me
one night i we were in the main room it
was like a tuesday or wednesday places
packed
and i watched her the earliest show and
she was [__] funny this girl and she
was really pretty
that's the contradiction she was a real
[__] knockout and she had tremendous
tits and they're out here so after like
the third week i couldn't take it no i i
didn't think i was doing her any favors
by not telling her so i pulled her aside
like a man i didn't tell her in front of
people like listen
you're really [__] funny you got a
career in this [__] but
you're mistaking you're thinking that
they want to see your tits i hope you
don't get mad at me you got nice tits i
agree with you they should see them but
when you're on stage you don't need
those [__] machine guns out
they're just beautiful machine guns you
don't need it you have the ability
to kill them whether you were an ugly
girl
i mean why are you showing those machine
guns there's no need for this [__]
rifles out now put them away and she
[__] put a sweater on went out there
and killed and she came back in and she
looked at me she goes thank you
you know i could be her father there was
no i didn't want to hit on her i was
just giving her advice
and i did the same with a lot of those
women from kate quigley me and felicia
attabond me and ali had a bang me and
whitney had a bun me and eliza had a
bong when i got in trouble eliza reached
out to me and said i support you i mean
this is because
they know who you are and they know how
you've been with them the store got a
bad rap over the years oh they don't put
enough women on stage that's [__]
that's [__] the women that deserve
to be there were there and i saw them
all and i supported them all and we
laughed together and we always had a
great [__] time so
whoever tells you that when you hear it
don't believe the hype
women grew there women grew there by
[__] huge numbers because all of us
took them and took care of them and told
them it was going to be fine that's what
you do with young account and i did the
same with male comics i i did the same
with everybody after a while
you're a comic but you're older you've
been doing it for 20 years
they look up to you as a
somebody to give them help or advice you
know it's not that you're their mentor
and nothing nothing like that i was
never though who would [__] have me
for a mentor you're out of your mind
you just talk to people
my guest today is eleanor kerrigan
uh
all the respect
from every part of my body goes eleanor
kerrigan
she was a waitress for 12 years at the
store when the store was nothing
she looked she listened she learned and
she kept her mouth shut
and for that
i [__] love her with all my heart
and she gets all the respect that i have
andrew takes her on the road
rogan has taken her on the road you know
we've all done shows with her we give
her all the respect in the world because
she did it
she [__] paid attention she sat there
she saw how to do it and now
she's one of the top women working in
the country i mean she doesn't have the
heat that whitney has
or [__] you know eliza but give it
time
eleanor is on her way i hope you enjoy
this interview
i'll be back stay black enjoy
what up
joe diaz what's happening beautiful
thank you for calling into the joint
today i'm so excited
is this light too bright no it looks
great i bring my light with me now in
case i have to do auditions or something
good for you that's the new [__]
thing now we got to bring a light you
look great i don't know i like your hair
like the show oh yeah i had to buy a new
blow dryer because my blow dryer blew up
so this one just flattens it
now where are you guys tonight
uh dallas uh fort worth
i'm sorry yeah fort worth hyenas it's
time it's a good club that's a great
club i haven't been there in a minute
you
good good i went to
hyenas in fort worth
and i did the
thursday night show
uh-huh
and when i walked out of there i was
[__] starving i had a coke rock in my
pocket but i had to eat something
because i couldn't do the coke on an
empty stomach
and there was a black dude with a white
wife beater like a white you know a
regular wife peter shirt on makes sense
[__] hand prints all over the stomach
it was as big as i was at the time i was
tipping the scales like 375. this
brother had to be like 390.
so we connected right off the bat you
know i'm saying like you just connect
you're a fat dude i'm a fat slob he was
selling pork chops with the bone
on white bread yes he was he was frying
them up the griddle was filthy
filthy
and nobody would else would buy the pork
chops except your [__] cuban buddy
over here i must hate six of those
[__] things they were delicious just
a point you didn't get sick
not at all on white bread i didn't get
sick those days once you put the cocaine
in your body
yeah get sick [__] mcdonald's ain't
gonna do [__] dude you're not saying you
could eat at [__] carl's jr
and you won't [__] die
that is amazing to buy meat on the side
of the road
but on a grill i've done it i've done it
a couple times i've gotten burgers like
outside of clubs you're right you go
outside of a club you're just like
starving you usually waste it i don't do
coke but i would get drunk and i'd be
like let me just eat you eat a million
hamburgers you're like oh the next day
you wake up
sick to your stomach
and you didn't get sick no that's my
white stomach my white irish stomach
it's very weak and you don't cause the
irish could eat anything you guys been
eating [__] dirty potatoes for 2 000
[__] years
those potato skins are filthy i eat them
i like potato skins but the irish taught
me how to eat the [__] skins
when i was a kid they're like yeah i eat
the skins i'm like i don't need no
[__] skins irish love the skin eat
the whole [__] thing they'll just
bite a potato but they like things with
no flavor that's the irish but boil the
flavor out of it and you got an irish
meal
did the the flamingo kid when
the singing eater
30 pounds of potatoes will i eat before
i die
cause they eat potatoes like a
[__] in the bronx and [__]
i'm telling you that's where i ate
potatoes in the bronx when i moved here
from cuba my mom had that operation in
the bronx
and my whole palate got [__] up there
the palace
italian ice
you know the bronx is the best when
you're a [__] kid they got everything
[__] uh pete always the puerto rican
italian ice where they there's a big
slab of ice oh yeah yeah and then they
just show you you know dirty hands they
don't wear gloves
covered at his best they don't give a
[__]
yeah some people are like oh you know
you get colder from different i'm like
no no you got to eat the right [__] like
we i think all that stuff blocks it for
us like that helps us fight it off
don't you think i was in a restaurant
the other night and the guy's walking
with this thing
and he's breathing on the [__] food
and [__] i'm like am i going to just eat
[__] colvin
i mean
is that what we're getting to right now
you know what variance is this dish
yeah you gotta bring the [__] dish
with a cover on it like room service
you can't be walking through a
restaurant with 80 people everybody
breathing the [__] covers in the air
now you eat a meatball next thing you
know the [__] meatball gave you
covered now you gotta go to the doctor
and tell them where'd you get covered i
don't know a meatball gave it to me you
fat [__]
get your life together it was somebody's
birthday and they brought a cake and we
all blew the candles out we spit on each
other and then we ate the cake and now
we're all dead that's that's where we're
at
that's crazy
that's [__] crazy now it's making a
comeback like herpes
you know nah now you got to worry about
[__]
having like a [__] thing on your lips
wait wait wait till they start shaving
eyebrows like in the
road warrior like you got to put two
knits in your eyebrows to let them know
you got covered how many times you got
it
[__] crazy
yeah tear drops of covid and how many
how many grandmothers died you gotta
have put [__]
these [__] grandma killers
these comedy club owners they call them
grandma killers they're [__] grandma
killers you go in their clubs now
there's no more pictures of comics it's
just pictures of good dead grandmothers
you know my mom had covet and she's 82
and she got through it and i swear she
had it twice because she got real sick
right before the panthemic and she don't
remember having covetous the second time
and i'll say mom you had kovitz she goes
no i didn't have cove and i'm like ma
you had covet so she's like i did not
have covet and then she'll go well
that's [__] i'm like what and she
goes they promised it would kill me
and i go god damn like that's the irish
in a nutshell right there just waiting
to die when the pandemic started i wrote
an obituary
i was like because the first two weeks
people told you you can't touch the mail
i still remember people telling me don't
go out and get your mail and i'm like
there's a check in the mailbox wipe it
down yeah
[__] down that's a sag check for
a dollar
i'm cashing it i don't care who it's
from it's an old residual
people like don't touch the mail don't
wipe down the boxes so we didn't really
know you know like we didn't [__]
know
yes so at the beginning i was scared and
i said the only way i can get unscathed
is if i just ride an obituary
and i just wrote an obituary out i took
a picture of my balls and i told my wife
if i die at the funeral parlor to use
the picture of my balls as the mass card
you know how people give a picture of
the same obituary in your balls no like
in the back like a trading like a
regular prayer card except for the saint
just your balls and then flip it around
joey diaz
you know [__] knee valdez
left a daughter a wife
some [__] waitresses at the store
[__] crazy
you know did comedy
i want to kill you just to get the card
i know
i was dying for people that's my last
thing i leave to the world you you're
all upset joey has died nelson you got a
prayer card there's a picture of my
[__]
he got us all the way in the end with
these [__] things and now you got to
hang it up on your refrigerator oh yeah
what do you do with the prayer cards put
it with the other prayer cards pop-pop
and joe diaz's balls
picture of saint michael a picture of
jesus and a picture of my nuts
[__] perfect i'm sitting in the right
hand of the lord
people are looking at it like i wonder
what patron saint this is
the balls that's what saint balls
nobody heard of that saint he doesn't
have a head
just balls that's it oh he's got a head
he's got wrecking balls coming balls
what's going on with you beautiful
nothing i'm just trying to survive man
we're on the road it's so weird people
are breaking our stones because we're
not like you know coming out and hanging
out can't hang out don't they know we're
in a [__] pandemic people are giving
me [__] online for wearing a mask go
[__] yourself
i'm trying to make money and if i get
sick i'm [__] you know if you're a
comic right now if you're looking at the
bands
you're looking at the bands like jimmy
florentine i feel so bad for he's the
kiss of death when it comes to concerts
he got four tickets for four different
concerts and they all got covert that
tells you something right oh my god
biscuit
friday night in atlantic city he was
supposed to go
they got covered something sons i i
don't know i don't want to say the wrong
band
right right stained and corn tomorrow
night corn the singer from corn got it
and leonard
guitar player from leonid skinner so
that's
that'll let you know what's going on
right now if you're on the road super
christian got it tim dillon got it yeah
you're gonna get it
unless you go out like guns and roses in
a bubble
yeah we're trying to bubble it you gotta
double it it's it doesn't you know as a
comic
it's so hard
like especially in austin
huh really why is austin gonna be rough
no no especially when we were in austin
because you so many people come to see
there's so many people comedy store
basically moved down here like a lot of
them so everybody's like come hang out
come hang out and i'm like
we can't you know what i mean so it's
like it's hard as a comic you want to go
[__] around and drink and just be normal
but you can't
you gotta like take a step back [__]
crazy in austin last weekend or you're
going back to austin this weekend i'm
going back to austin um on thursday but
we were in austin
saturday and sunday
and now you guys is andrew going with
you back to austin no that's no no no no
this is just me i'm going to do some
shows at the vulcan and the creek in the
cave
and then do some podcasts and stuff and
you and andrew have a lot of work left
uh yeah we have a couple yeah
and some of them are his gigs like
makeup gigs from last year and then some
of them are just me headlines like i'm
headlining um
atlantic city the uh celebrity
as it's called the celebrity theater and
the claridge yeah so
i'm doing that august 28th but the night
before we're in chicago and that's his
gig so i'm opening for him coming back
and then
just going right to atlantic city i'm
sorry i didn't come to see you last time
you guys were at uncle vinnie's oh yeah
but again stitches in my [__] mouth
you had one stitches in my [__] mouth
58 years old
you know when does it end
when it's going to get worse
you know i look at my dick i look at my
balls
it's a horrible situation i don't even
look at myself naked you know when you
come out of the shower you always got
that mirror and you just look like you
know what's going on my body i had to
stop like two weeks ago
my dick i don't know what happened to it
my ball stack is [__] old
i'm old you know is it between your
knees now is that is it that long it's
kept it's it's kept its uh you know
it's kept its buoyancy yeah yeah the
bounce is still there that's good bounce
three ounce but little cuban beans in
there just bouncing show it to nobody no
more even as a goof like he can't show
it to nobody i don't even show it to my
wife anymore it's
it's all over you get so great so
self-conscious yeah
you know i had to shave everything i had
like a heat rash
for a couple weeks i get you know the
humidity and [__] like this oh forget it
listen i i didn't remember all the [__]
i hated about jersey
and the thing i hate the most is the
[__] humidity the humidity when that
thing gets in your [__] with the
swamp
and you don't even take a [__] but your
ass smells you like it it draws the
stink out of your kidneys and [__] i
went to a restaurant sunday night and
they brought a clove of garlic
a clove
and i'm eating the whole [__] thing
i'm seeing that jimmy ain't eating my
wife ain't eating and i'm popping
clothes like they're [__] tic tacs
who eats cloves of garlic that's crazy
were you a vampire it was a whole garlic
but they put it on the dish with the
steak and you could squeeze them out and
pop them out and eat them
i must have like edamame that's funny
just like edamame you've never been to
the garlic restaurant on on uh oh the
stinking rose no yeah unless you and
again okay they give you a garlic a
whole thing of garlic
but they steam it and just gonna put in
butter on your bread you
push the garlic out and you smear it on
your bread and you eat that oh
[__] tremendous but don't go
you can't go to the stinking rose if you
have to do something afterward
anything because it's disgusting you
could smell it driving up los angeles
you can't [__] stink it stinks
terrible
you stink
terrible my ex had a rule no garlic if i
ate garlic two days and i didn't see him
for two days i'd be with him and he'd go
when did you have garlic and i'm like
what the [__] does that just stay on you
so i'm afraid of garlic because he
wouldn't go near a man no you got to eat
garlic it's good for your heart it
cleans out the vows
takes your stomach over and you blow i
blew a fart
sunday night the first official fart
from the garlic was like three hours
later
it was silent it was small
but i blew up my basement that my wife
came down and she goes jesus christ the
cats blew up the [__] uh little box i
go don't blame it on the cats not this
time this is all papa and then monday i
went to the gym
and there's like this couple that they
won't shut the [__] up at the gym
they constantly talk he constantly talks
he requests bad music he was doing
setups it was perfect i was doing the
axes outside hitting the tire and i
walked and there's a little alley in the
back
just a little segment where you walk in
it's not closed off he was in there
doing the sit-ups on the [__]
sit-up machine i know he was coming into
it he was coming into it so i just stood
right there
with my back to him and i dropped the
[__] one of those long rippers
yeah like a dentist
like it just lives it just came out warm
out of my ass i was doing [__]
crunches and hitting the tire so i was
working it i could feel the fart
developing it was sticking to the ribs
and i cupped it you have to cup it like
a
oh my god my brothers used to do that
put it in my mouth and you push the
[__] fart down
and i blew that far and he walked into
it his face was red i looked at him from
the [__] squat machine
he walked into it his face was as red as
my shirt and when he inhaled it on the
poi on the sit-up i could see he just
stopped he froze and then he went down
slowly
and he's like it stinks in here what's
that smell because he's just he's a
little [__] up in there
and i went up to one of the trainers i
go he ain't gonna say a word for ten
[__] minutes now
and he didn't say a word he just walked
around with his nose shut
just tell him it's good for your heart
he told his wife not to go on that side
don't come on this side it smells funny
i don't know i think one of the toilet
broke
you clear a gym with your fart that's
nice i clear the corner of the [__]
gym i pay that much it's not a big gym
but i took that [__] the one
guy rich he's like a crazy brooklyn guy
he's like i smelt that fart that was
tremendous
that girl was [__] tremendous doesn't
want some of my best work
i mean you're getting congratulated for
a [__] that's amazing that must be some
real art it's an art i don't fart
anymore like i used to because i stopped
eating the garlic pills i would eat them
on purpose or on leak because i wanted
to [__] [__] them up you know what
i'm saying
poorly
taste the flavor of my muffler
and to taste the patois the [__] and
he would so
he would just sit in that little corner
and he'd walk out of there smelling like
a stinking rose doug
but then
you could not eat that and go to i went
to like i ate that one time
in 23 years i lived in l.a i went there
once never went there and i went
straight to the comedy store afterward
and i [__] stunk
the girl that was with stunk
it's just a stinky [__] proposition
you know what i'm saying it throws the
ph off on your [__] and your
[__] so the two is just banging and
stinks together i think no we i took
showers and i'd had [__] she had to take
a shower too ain't nobody coming in here
with a garlic [__]
or garlic flavored [__] in my house and
[__] so how did you get stitches in your
mouth
before i left [__] la
i had to do
a cap and [__]
oh okay
my coke tooth had [__] up the one in
the front
and then replace it and then they had a
you know you just can't go to the
dentist for one tooth
oh it never works then they start with
the well this one won't match that one
who gives a [__]
yeah
can i kill your model cares yeah this
one doesn't match and if we do those
then we got to do the ones in the bottom
so i ended up
doing eight [__] teeth and my little
dracula fang over here i got [__] got
infected and my and now they're infected
my gums
are infected again so
i gotta go back on the 30th
yeah
i have nightmares from the dentist
because as a kid this tooth i got it
knocked out by a football this older kid
through the football i went to catch it
i thought i was tough you know
i hit so hard the tooth went up it
didn't come out until like fifth or
sixth grade and then it came straight
out and it was jet black and they were
like oh
and my mom didn't have money so we had
to go to like dennis schools and we'd go
in the dentist school and i might they
do work for free because they want to
learn and my mom's like yeah see if you
can fix that my brothers used to call me
yuck mouth because my teeth were all
[__] up and then i go in there and
they're in there and they're like it's
like learning so they're in your mouth
and you hear oops and i'm like the [__]
is oops no oops no i have enough oops in
here don't oops me
but they fixed it and i got braces for
free
and i have braces forever and then i let
my bottom teeth go so now i have to get
invisalign
jesus christ
they never stop never stops
but now i have to pay for it i can't go
to any dental school it's not too old
you know but that i do i don't know how
but i have a upper like i have teeth and
it's
i shouldn't because they were so bad and
they i got them knocked out a lot it's
crazy because i lived in like four areas
where you could go to the schools
and i had friends that would say you
want a massage like in boulder when i
lived in boulder it was a place it was a
massage school
so if you want to get a massage for like
[__] 10 bucks
you know because they're learning and
then there was another place where i
live
oh when i lived in boulder there was
also a place that a girl told me you
come in and get your hair cut at any
time you want cause we
we're students i went in there one time
half my hair was blue the other one was
[__] green i said i ain't going back
there no more that was the only time i
went to one of those schools i'm not
going to lie to you because those are
scary because you never know what's
going to happen my sister was doing that
she was in high school again you
remember when you go to school and you
could have um you could go for a trade
like instead of going to high school
they would let you you go to regular
academic for half the day and then go to
another school and learn a trade my
sister was becoming a hairdresser she's
10 years older she gave me a body wave
in the third grade i looked like such a
dick at my communion because i had this
ugly body wave but she was testing it on
my hair and my mom let her
awful i'd have to go to school like a
poodle for years
because of her so when she shaved one
side of my head
[__] karen
that's her name too
you look really good thank you i can't
believe i have hair because of her
i like the shirt made in south philly i
[__] love this shirt man that's you
made in south [__] philly how's
the colbert situation in philly they
don't even give a [__] they don't give a
[__] there's no ass they breathe on you
oh yeah my buddy that makes these shirts
his name's tony bat dirty mug is
unbelievable he's doing shirts for me
too and so uh he uh he's like what are
you wearing a mask for which wrong and i
go i know i'm just you know because i'm
traveling a lot and he's like you don't
need no mess i'm like i do need a mask
and he i go he goes didn't you guys
didn't you get covered when your mom got
to go yeah he goes you can't get it
again
i go thanks fauci just give me a t-shirt
i think steve simone got it twice
i think you can get it i think it will
be mild but you can get it
because i definitely think my mom had it
twice she was so sick in february before
the shutdown
and then we shut down
she went to the doctors somebody in the
office had it
she got it
brought it home and then we all got it
taking care of her
because she was
going through some dumb [__] you know
normal 82 year old [__]
but now she's 83 she's killing it yeah
83 kovit already came and went she got
the world by the balls you're a lucky
lady i don't know at least you got good
genes
you know you're going to be live for a
little [__] time 10 kids you know no
uterus she's killing it no uterus the
coven [__]
didn't take it down i i
send you my love you're [__] lucky
you still got your mom around oh yeah i
talked to her every day not to have a
[__] mom you still got your mom
around you know
it's crazy funny i don't think of myself
with this cobit like i didn't really
think of what i was losing with this
cobot i thought about
because all comics like us are losing
his money
yeah that's it we're just losing money
so i didn't really think about it like
that i thought about the younger comics
the guys that have been doing comedy for
four years
three years five years three years like
that breaks my heart because i knew how
i was
at the five year level you weren't going
to tell me i wasn't getting on stage
because of some [__] disease yeah
like you weren't gonna tell me like i
remember you know i had to actually
think back and go let's be honest with
yourself joey
at the five-year mark you weren't going
to [__] stop me i'm going on stage i
i used to if i couldn't go it was like a
drug for me it had become an addiction
it had become an addiction like any
other addiction i had and i would
if worst case scenario i would hit a
karaoke spot
oh yes
i did everything remember we were doing
strip clubs in l.a i was doing cheetahs
i was doing that was insane i loved it
it's insane you have to you know at the
20-year mark 30-year mark you're already
established you're just losing money you
can write at home you know what i'm
saying like you could you're so you're
so mature with comedy that you're like
okay
this isn't that bad
i feel bad for the guys that you know
josh potter
had like so many things going on and
covered
swept them from them the guys that were
just ready to headline just right there
yeah you know it's like when i was doing
like in
2008 or nine
whenever the strike was i was doing my
name as earl and i had like four
episodes oh yeah and i'm like this is
great i'm gonna be on tv for pilot
season
that's so great which means that
[__] february you're on tv
some producers
maybe i could use that fat [__] for my
show you know
and all of a sudden it was a [__]
writer's strike i was heartbroken
like i'm like what do you mean a writer
strike i gotta go to work i gotta i got
my name is zero with michael rappaport
we're having a good time killing it yeah
i'm killing it and now you [__]
come up with a strike like i was [__]
heartbroken but that could only happen
to me at that time you know what i'm
saying like i have
all my [__] trees planted on this
[__] tv show being on tv in february
and now
there's a [__] writer strike so like
throughout this whole thing
i didn't really think of the older
comics like you have something you could
do you know what i'm saying you could go
by the script you know what you're doing
already yeah i thought about the younger
guys like five six years they were just
getting ready to feature
like they just got their first feature
week mark march
18th night the march 19th and everything
closed down on the 17th or the 16th of
march it was a monday
so you're like what the [__] do i do
like i felt so bad
for those guys you know so
i don't want you to think i'm you know i
i'm not mad at you or anything i'm just
saying that
like i
i do feel bad for all the comics you
know because it's money involved and i
thought yeah that aspect but i didn't
feel bad you know the money will come
later we'll go on the road later we'll
figure it out yeah in the beginning i
think everybody was in panic mode like
[__] but i was jo i was making jokes
that um i'm the pandemic comic because
they're like who draws 30 people can we
get when you come to kansas city i'm
like hey man i've got no kids i'm good
i'll come and i would fly out in june
like i was going to places that because
i was already booked but they got all
cancelled and then once they opened up a
little they were like hey would you come
here and i did i went to arizona i went
to
minnesota i was all over the place just
do and that's why i recorded an album at
uncle vinnie's because i was doing i was
working that out i had already planned
to do it before the pandemic but i was
lucky enough to go out and we only had
you know i think they could only sell
like 30 tickets so they were like who
would want to work in front of 30 people
i'm like i will
so i did i got lucky you know and i was
doing
and then money got cut in half you know
obviously everything so you're you're
still struggling but at the same time i
was still getting to do
what i wanted to do and i was able to
record the album at uncle vinnie's in
april so
it was very exciting you have no idea
like when all the comics talk like from
the comedy store
how many people are really proud of you
oh
that's so sweet you have i think hari
came down here maybe two months ago we
went to get chinese food and we were
talking about it
we were talking about you know the jump
that eleanor made you know like eleanor
paid attention for 10
years without doing 12
12 years without doing but you paid
attention
and i always tell when people always say
to me well i'm thinking of starting
comedy
if i know the person really well and i
like them i'll go listen the best advice
just get a job around it
around it it's a hundred percent good
job around it
you know i don't care if you're a
doorman i don't care if you're a
bartender i don't care if you're a bus
boy get a job around it look at our
pumpkin
yeah look at our pumpkin
i mean
literally like she's like you did it
first i'm like no no i did not i wasn't
a waitress i would never i i left as a
waitress came back a year later as a
comic and mitchy the reason i was so
nervous to tell mitzi is because and i
put this quote on my album but mitzi
would always go oh no another waitress
turned comic it's gonna be awful
and she was not wrong she wasn't wrong
but punky came in as a comic you know
what i mean i didn't come in as a comic
i had no interest but punky came in as a
comic worked her ass off as a waitress a
bartender whatever job they she would be
able to do to get stage time in any way
shape or form now she's on snl i think
she's doing a show right now
she she booked the show so she had to
cancel a lot of her live gigs
she's killing it she's killing it and i
couldn't be happier or prouder of her
you know they they had that's a real
product of the
comedy story yeah yeah
you know it pissed me off because
all these women were talking [__] about
the comedy store oh please don't get me
angry yeah no idea that
a lot of the male comics in there
were giving love to the females the
weight you know
100 we were excited for you we were
really excited for you i think
you know if i have a i still remember
going to the comedy store like before
the pandemic
and me and joe watching you
like in the original room one night and
going can you [__] believe i don't
know
like this is [__] she's killing up here
like who the [__] would thought you know
and so awesome
so many people
from the store like even when punky got
sad night live
dog i think i cried
me the same people
i knew what love we had for each other
whether it's felicia you
allie wrong [__]
the little blonde chick that's like a
prowess on stage eliza jessica yeah i
love jessica michelle singer oh my god
people had no idea how close we were
i'll never forget ripping my [__]
hamstring and being on the floor in pain
and going what the [__] and annie led
him and coming up to me going you want
me to get somebody a sucky dick
i'm like
do you on
your blow job
your dick sucked and i'm like annie what
the [__] she's like she's the one the
guy's here
you're on the floor you know
people don't understand it pissed me off
so much and you want to yell but you're
like it's not gonna they don't know
they don't [__] know they get it from
one girl that says i went to the store
and i was mistreated they didn't give me
a spot
yeah they're not gonna you gotta work
for it you gotta really put the time you
gotta really like stop getting on
twitter and complaining about [__] just
go write jokes like annie and i say it
all the time annie i think she wrote it
like because somebody was giving the
store a hard time because they didn't
understand how you get in the store they
thought you your manager calls and then
you just get spot that's not how life
works that's not how it works over there
maybe at other clubs but not at the
comedy store you have to come up i
remember as
[__] as tommy was
what's his name was doing the um
the emmys or something and jeff chetty
brought him in
oh [__] he's a big name and i can't
think i could see his face jason sedakis
he walked in and he goes hey he wants to
work out some stuff and tommy was like
well he's not a regular i was like holy
[__]
but he goes well we can give him some
time in the valley room you know
it's like dude you gotta go through the
process of the store you don't get to
just walk in there you don't get to just
come in and become a regular because you
have credits i mean a little bit now but
not before
no
listen you can have 20 credits if you
can't cut it up on stage it ain't going
to help you credits are not going to
help you so knock it off with the
[__] credits
hard work
that's the credit that you need credits
don't do dick for you that's what people
you know there's nothing
more annoying
than
going through comedy
and then reflecting on the stories when
you were
emcee
and a feature act especially in mc
i still remember all the headliners that
gave me a hard time
like this is my name you know don't
forget to mention nbc it's not going to
matter
it doesn't matter you're going to eat a
bag of dicks i saw your act you're
terrible
i could go up there and say that jesus
and you wrote jokes together it doesn't
matter you're gonna it doesn't matter
you know i was lucky enough to be
a host at the broker in boulder that's
where i really caught oh okay
it was a one-nighter for tribble
and those california comics were
failures in
california that's why you're doing
triple runs as a headliner i'm sorry to
say
and they would treat you a feature act
the guy who was emceeing like [__] they
would treat me like [__] i would have to
check them and tell them
don't forget how [__] you know put
you in the trunk of a car and [__] you
know i'd have to check them but it was
always you know
uh
you forgot to say friday night lights
who gives a [__] you were an extra
right exactly what about the dudes who
would tell you that they were in a movie
and they weren't really an extra
and they lied to you you know i remember
being a feature act and seeing a
headliner talking to people after the
show and they would ask them like so
what's next for you are you in any and i
would feel like going stop it he's on
the triple run he's in no danger
what are you asking if there's any
television in his life there's not
there's nothing in his life he's a bum
this guy you know there were people who
tell me that don't go to l.a you're not
going to get any spots i still remember
being at the improv on a sunday night it
was like my first sunday at the improv
and i'm like i've been here two weeks
i'm getting spots at the improv what
were those jerk-offs on the road talking
about
you're not gonna get any spots because
they don't work hard and they're not
funny
they're missing everything they have the
credits
they're coming they're showing up
but they're not funny you're missing the
key element you got to be funny and at
the comedy star when the when girls [__]
on the comedy store and and i do know
for a fact that there were some girls
that had some issues with some male
comics not the establishment itself but
some male comics whatever but they don't
represent
the whole place there's a small group of
idiots that did some dumb [__] right but
every time a girl a female comic says
well you know [__] this story they don't
put enough women on or this or that it's
like you're discrediting every [__]
one of us that busted our ass and get in
there and bump those [__] guys off
the line up because we're better than
that you you should eliza schlesinger
i don't care if you like her don't like
her her hard work her work ethic is
unfucking unbelievable
she had a bad [__] relationship and
made a move wrote a movie about it and
then
got it on netflix and i think she's
recording her i don't know ninth special
that's and she's selling out theaters
and
no one says a [__] word about that
they're just like oh [__] they don't
hire women what are you crazy candace
thompson writes on every show she's
[__] phenomenal like what are you
saying there's so many com leslie jones
there's so many of us and every time
they say they discredit how hard we
[__] work to get in there and stay in
there annie letterman too she's moving
up in the ring she's one of my absolute
favorites as a person
as a person and just [__] hilarious
everybody knows i love annie uh
so i mean i i have my favorites of
course but when somebody's funny like
they hated adam because they're like oh
he only puts on people that have credits
no he doesn't he puts on people that
make him [__] laugh and he was in
charge and if you made him laugh and you
did well in that room you got spots if
you didn't he took you out just like
mitzi would do
tommy did it too
adam was a very good talent coordinator
excellent excellent i've had my
favorites in there i really like scott
day oh yeah love's got that scott garcia
was one of my favorites i was out there
with him and the andrew arguing one
night
him and andrew oh because he anger was
banned right
yes i remember this that's how i met
andrew through scott day an argument
with gut day
what do you mean i'm banned he just
banned every week still talk to scott
day on facebook me too yeah i love you
he's a good guy
i've never forgotten him i never forgot
what he did for you know i used to talk
to him i used to go in and go dog i keep
bombing in here
yeah what to do like i didn't want to
hide the fact like i would there were
some nights he would stay late
yeah and he if he liked you he really
would work he would push that you guys
he pushed for me and that's because i
was honest with him because i went up to
him and told him i was struggling like
i'm having a hard time in here some
nights
you know mitzy you couldn't tell her you
were struggling because then she slowly
right back into the mouth of the lion i
went up to mitch and i was like dog i
struggle in the main room don't put me
in there no more you're in there friday
and saturday [__] and you know
i hated going in there even though it
was a lot more money
i didn't know i wanted to be honest with
you
so i would go up to and go missy i'm
struggling on the weekends in the main
room i can't follow aj jamal
i've been
trying to bring up this guy's name for
years i got to feature for him in
arizona and i was so excited and he's
like you're doing comedy it was years
ago i have not seen him
oh my god he was in arizona i was so
excited and that uh dan madonia was with
me he was the gonna be the host and we
were so excited and he goes who's aj
jamal i go no one likes you
how do you not know aj dwell he's so
[__] funny
and i mean he killed
me for you guys at home that no no aj
jamal
missy used to give me spots behind him
and died
and domino on saturday i [__] hated
dom
because he would [__] light that room
on fire
and then say [__] to me as i was walking
on stage you [__]
you guinea bastard here yeah just
breaking balls
you're breaking my balls before i bomb
i'm gonna go in there and eat a bag of
dicks
i'll never forget one night while i was
driving down there and i got pulled over
to get a ticket i'm like thank god
i don't have to follow don murray
tonight or [__]
i'd rather pay the 100 ticket i used to
and explain to the people at home you
know in the original room it's fifteen
dollars yeah the main room in 97 and 98
was 225 you know on saturdays it was
maybe 180.
i didn't want the money i'd rather be
broke even though i was a junkie on coke
i didn't want to admit you don't pay
i'd rather get the fifteen dollars and
try to find the cell phone and sell it
to the bank robbers from st louis
remember those black dudes i used to
have i gotta yeah always do i remember
remember they were bankrupt
every night i go into the store i think
i left my cell phone i didn't even have
a [__] i think i had a pager enough
money for jj the king of beepers the
[__]
no remember paul mooney used to goof on
jj he had a joke that wrapped up with jj
the king of b king of beepers yeah yeah
for people who don't know jj the king of
beepers
was that the first one
he was the
prostitutes investor
what's the big madam
oh uh uh heidi slice heidi fleisch he
was partners with heidi fleisch jj the
king of beepers when we moved to l.a the
[__] store was here he had like 10
million beepers in there and then
there's stuff he just brought back so
many memories smaller small it was right
behind wendy's
on set behind hoy's walk yep yeah the
whole little school
it's he had jj the king of beepers must
have had [__] 20 offices when i moved
to l.a and then over time it just kept
getting smaller and smaller and then he
got arrested for the heidi fleiss thing
right something happened and the thing
just shrunk the [__] nothing i have
to go in there once a month and pay 30
bucks for the [__] pager
the [__] we're used to
do you remember like i dated my wife
as boyfriend and girlfriend but we
didn't say nothing to nobody because we
didn't want mitch oh i know
and one night we walked into rock and
roll ralph's and we saw you
you were the first one to know we were
dating and i remember
i was like oh boy what are you doing
with her and i'm like
i don't know she don't even [__] eat
butter she eats margarine like i don't
even know what i'm doing with her i made
it by butter for the first time she's
like i've been eating margarine for you
who eats my white people it's disgusting
i [__] hate margarine but that first
thing that was the first time we ever
went shopping together we we're together
like three weeks and you busted us
like what the [__] do we do now i got
eyes everywhere this is what i was gonna
say about scott day like the difference
between scott day and adam uh eager was
that adam
he was the guy
like with scott like you could go talk
to scott and tell him oh no i'm not
doing well i don't know what to do
whatever because he wasn't the main
person he could if he wasn't giving you
spots he could say oh well mitzi's just
not giving you spots you know what i
mean whereas adam was the guy so people
would attack adam and be like i have
credits how dare you not give me spots
and he's like
like he has nobody to blame at all he
can't say oh mitzi or this or whatever
so he just got his ass kicked so he
would hide in the back of the comedy
store and i'd be like adam white hiding
behind the door he's like they're
[__] coming at me i'm like get in
your car and get out of here but he
would try to like stay and like watch
people to see if they were getting
better or not and they weren't no one
gave him the respect he deserved maybe
it's because we we knew him too well
when he was a manager we would [__] on
them like i just know about him as a
manager i knew adam as a talent like i
never voted
so i knew adam as a talent coordinator
never as a manager or anything else i
thought he was great
i agree there's nothing better than
sexually harassing adam yeah which is
what i do on a regular basis i just did
i saw him in austin and i grabbed his
ass and he said okay come on and i'm
like come on let me see
get away from me i'm like come on we all
want to see that hog let me see it
it gets so mad i don't know so the cd
comes out
friday uh
yeah or august 20th is that friday
friday yes friday how do you feel about
it
i'm excited at first um
you know because you you record the
album it's with the
um 800 pound gorilla people they're so
nice
and
great people and they sent um all the
both nights in tracks
so i had to listen to it i don't know
100 [__] times because i was like
this is terrible the first week i was
like it's awful i'm not doing it i'm not
putting it out it's the worst album i
ever heard and then this the guy goes um
well where do you where where do we go
from here and i'm like uh obviously i
quit the business and i moved back to
philadelphia and just marry whoever's
getting out of prison in the next couple
weeks
he was like
um you might want to take a day or two
and not listen and then go back to it
and then i did and i think you know as a
comic we just beat this [__] out of
ourselves and you want it you want it to
be funny you want
you want them to experience what you you
know because everybody does what's funny
to them but you also want other people
to you know accept it and so
i i went through it through i had index
cards all over with different nights
different bits blah blah blah and then i
finally got it down to what i what i
like and i'm proud of
and that's it and the album cover they
killed it with that
because it's called ladylike because
every time i get off stage
after working with andrew he'll go that
was ladylike
so i call it ladylike because
i'm a lady
i'm very [__] proud of you
and i'm very proud of them what you've
accomplished
i'm about to call you a friend because
we've been friends for 23 [__] years
from that dungeon
jesus it's so long how did that happen
it just happened you know it just it
just rolls by you're like [__] you know
when i was first going in then i'd see
you in there we go how long are we gonna
last in here really where are we gonna
get fired from here
every time i leave there i would be oh i
was fired every other week yeah me too i
was like i would fire myself i'm like
that's the last time i'm doing this
i'm not going down at a bomb again
but she kept giving me love and she kept
you know we were a family
yeah a sick family but we're a family we
were a family you know paulie hit me up
the other day and he's like hey bubba
and i go paulie what the [__] is wrong
with you we're like brothers
we're like brothers we had the same
mother
yeah we all had the same mother she was
a that's right their dad was like i'm
i'm out of mothers
like all my mothers have died
like when my mother died i had like 20
adopted mothers mrs sabatino i'm kind of
one mother terry's mom
i'm not the one mom i used to have 15
[__] moms mrs ronnie died mitzy short
died you know
mr sabatino died
miss lebrano still alive i got like two
mothers left
i went from having no mother to 20
mothers and then
you know i was like in heaven who's got
20 mothers right you know you called me
a [__] i just smacked you 20
times because i got 20 mothers
who's got 20 moms i called 20 women mom
mom what's going on mom mom and little
by little over the years my moms have
disappeared man so i'm down
a mother-in-law
what a [__] shame
that is it sucks but it's true it's like
when i see paulie i'm like oh hey like i
feel comfortable even though we would
fight like crazy named paulie oh my god
because it was you know mitzi would
you know be like oh you gotta ask
eleanor what's the worst thing you say
to the son
and he's like to [__] [__] her you know
and i get it i get it but he came in a
couple of months ago
i was at the store it was late night it
was very
dead like
the the original room was packed but the
main room was closed the belly room was
closed
so it not
available he's not wrong he's not wrong
that was a good time
you know eleanor they can't take that
from us
never and we we laughed we had the best
night that night and paulie was part of
it which didn't normally happen because
we were kind of like
oh that's the boss's son you know we
were like hey polly but then we would
you know box him out for the most part
especially wait staff but
we
that night he hung out with the comics
he was a little tipsy but like not crazy
it was so [__] funny we had so much
fun it was like meet him kirk fox uh
ryan o'neal
um i forget who kurt metzger and we were
just laughing and giggling and telling
stories
and heart the bartender
i don't miss comedy but i missed the
story
yeah those bonding those fun nights
where it's just like towards the end
when you'd watch on tuesday nights when
you'd walk into the main room
gina would give you a blunt
there'd be tricks giving massages there
was a chick in the back giving massages
yeah i never went back there i'm like
i'm not going back there she was a
sweetheart you wanted
hey she wants to be in comics so she put
herself around it she's great
yeah she was great she's great you know
the masseuse the abx capsule guys i
would leave oh yeah
they would come up to me and go we're
gonna put it in your coffee
they gave me a bag a goodie bag even if
i wasn't on the show oh yeah we got a
bag for you we got a bag for you i love
you guys i miss gino i miss
you know nobody understands that
gino's great what gave me the momentum
to go out on the weekends was those
tuesday nights at the store they were
everywhere
that was the you know
that was our ball night that was our
ball that was it
i would drink four
before i'd go down there
and a joint incredible
and a half of xanax and i would run down
and i'd be [__] ready because i would
get so much anxiety in there
like it would be so big on tuesday
nights it's great i do tripoli show and
then if i was lucky i get a spot in the
o.r and then the belly roll and just
[__] bounce around i was like
you want to leave you're just great
you're in this one building you get to
do three four shows a night
it's [__] phenomenal i can't wait for
it to really come back i don't know if
it will those were tripoli shows right
this tuesday
[__] amazing sometimes rogan would do
them but tripoli was that was mostly his
thing the girl that was great oh yeah
yeah uh
yeah
i just sarah
no the yes sarah mello she just asked
caramella for a reference for some i'm
like sorry you got it you anything you
want she's terrific yeah what a great
place man and uh
i'm sad i'm in new jersey now but it's
in my [__] heart you can't take it
away from me right marine of comedy
can't take the comedy store away from me
you can't take those tuesday nights you
can't take those bombings behind aj
jamal you can't take those bombings away
from me from don barrera you know you
just can't this is that little [__] yeah
how is he have you seen him of course i
talk to dom all the time i'm going to
give him a call tonight i'm happy oh
please do he's so he's a great guy i i
still talk to a lot of guys i still i
talked to theo the other night
that was okay
i talked to a lot of people just
separate staggered yeah sure i talked to
kate the other night it's staggered you
know so you check in with people yeah
george perez you know uh
croix
i love georgia i love jorge but you keep
doing what you're doing i'm really
[__] proud of you man i mean thank
you i'm i love seeing your face you look
great by the way yeah we're trying when
jimmy told me your album was coming out
i'm like i'm getting around this week we
got a break i had too much [__] on here
i gotta have a pretty girl on here the
last 10
weeks keep my [__] tucked keep your [__]
between your legs for now
uh where can they find your album on
friday
uh it drops everywhere on friday so
wherever you find albums itunes we had
it exclusively streaming on pandora and
sirius
so that was the you know it's playing
all week you can stream it but for
purchase it doesn't come out until 8 20
and it'll be on itunes everything
wherever else you get albums so you need
something you call yes sir
and i'll be over that side so i'll hit
you guys up maybe i'll swing out august
28th
august 28th i'm in atlantic city but in
september i think it's the 24th 23rd
24th 25th something like that i'm at
uncle vinnie's i don't have my calendar
in front of me but i'm doing it you're
going to be back there again i saw
you're going to be back yeah
headlining at the end of september there
so i have to go back to the dentist on
the 30th
and this [__] he's going to rip
out the [__] racket those miserable
[__] oh they're going to rip out the
fang they're going to rip out this
that's steve simone you're making me
oh you're going to steve's brother no he
put this in there
15 years ago 20 years ago when he had to
practice in santa monica yeah and now
he's saying that this is no good no more
so we're gonna take it out and we're
gonna see where we're at they're
probably gonna have to [__] stitch
everything again
oh they never like anybody else's work
these [__] no no so they did it
all wrong let me reconfigure your whole
mouth [__] you
i don't know what the [__] made me made
this swell you know i wish it was
19 up to 92 000 i could say i ate some
bad [__] at the store and your gums got
swollen but i can't even use brat and
[__] as an excuse for this [__]
i love you eleanor stay black give my
best to andrew good luck i love you too
you're the best give my best to red band
and everybody in austin and uh yes
i love you i'm very proud of you and i
love your success
thank you so much for having me it was
so good to see you and hang out at the
joint with joey you got it stay black
and stay beautiful i'll give you a call
next week you got it love you got it
love you thanks
all right you bad [__] i hope
you enjoy that in-law kerrigan guess
what
laughing gas is back in stock you bad
[__] they put a pound in there
last friday they're putting another
pound in there this [__] friday the
20th and then at the end of the month
they're coming in with the big [__]
grow so do not forget to stop in over at
the ice cream shop and studio city tell
them uncle joey sent you i want to thank
eleanor i want to thank [__] ice
cream shop but most importantly i want
to thank you [__] for watching
to join with uncle joey every monday and
wednesday and supporting us
i hope you enjoyed eleanor kerrigan do
not forget to go to itunes
or any of the platforms her album is
playing on sirius i don't know what
channel you're gonna have to [__] oh
probably the the comedy the dirty comedy
channel i forget raw dog raw dog she's
probably playing on road dog listen to
her support eleanor kerrigan she's one
of us guys she's a [__] savage and i
have watched it grow
and i'm very proud of it but anyway
thank you very much for supporting the
joint thank you for supporting uncle
joey thank you for supporting mike by
from one by one podcast i want to give a
shout out to my man jay it was his
birthday last week i promised him and
his [__] friend from segovia that i
would give him a shout out and here we
are happy birthday jay i love you
[__] have a great week and i'll
see you guys monday morning tip top
magoo ready to go have a great weekend
stay black and don't forget draftkings
on [__]
saturday for the pacquiao ooga's fight a
dollar to win a hundred dollars i'm
trying to make you guys some money and
now for a word for my [__]
sponsors jack
all right i want to thank you
[__] for listening today i want
to thank eleanor kerrigan
do not forget to get her cd on friday it
comes on an 800 pound gorilla it'll be
on itunes and all the other streaming
services and it's also playing
on siriusxm probably road dog i don't
know for sure
the joint is brought to you by cbd lion
listen when it comes to cbd
nobody knows dick except the lion i've
been working with them for three four
years now they're tremendous i use their
melatonin gummies at night to sleep like
a baby i use their tape to put on my
knee and i've even smoked their hemp
flower just to see how it is and it
relaxes you it's fantastic it's great go
to cbdlion.com right now preston joey
and let cbd do the work
cbd lion the best cbd available on the
market today how do i know because i
live it i'm not here to [__] blow
smoke up your ass cbd lion.com
joey will get you 20 off your favorite
cbd which is cbd line
the joint is also brought to you by
upstart
listen to me whether it's praying off
credit cards or consolidating your debt
get a simple fixed monthly payment debt
is a nightmare you can't sleep at night
it takes away from who you are i was
there for a long time and i know the
feeling
this is why i'm coming to you with
upstart.com right now they can lower
your monthly payments
right off the bat over a million people
have used upstart to get out of debt
unlike other lenders upstarts look at
more than just your credit score they
take into account your income and
employment history this means that they
can offer smarter rates with trusted
partners just a five minute online rate
check you can get approved the same day
and can receive funds as fast as one
business day if that has taken over your
life it's time to get a fresh start with
upstart.com do me a favor
go to upstart.com
joey don't forget to use the url to let
them know i sent you
upstart is going to help you get out of
debt
give you a little loan and take care of
you because when you're in debt
it can feel like it's never going to end
upstart can help upstart's a fast easy
way to get a personal loan to pay off
your debt it starts with you going to
upstart.com
joey again that's upstart.com
joey and i got a disclaimer for you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided by your loan
application
go to upstart.com
joey and get out of debt today
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my personal favorites i'm an old man
blue chew
listen to me
erectile dysfunction sucks especially
when you're right there and you're about
to perform
blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis at a fraction of the
cost you could take it anytime anywhere
day or night you're like joey but i
don't need it my hammer works perfect
that's great but you always need a
little extra confidence to give her a
better stabbing and the process is
simple you sign up at bluetooth.com you
talk to one of the licensed medical
providers and once you're approved boom
you'll receive the prescription within
days it ships right to your door in a
discreet package not even the mailman
knows what's in there bluetooth tablets
are made in the usa prepared and shipped
directly it's way cheaper than any
pharmacy so if you could benefit from
extra confidence tell them uncle joey
sent you blue chew can help and they got
a special deal for you try blue chew
free
joy what are you talking about don't
[__] with me free
with promo code joey you're just gonna
pay five dollars for shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code joey to receive
your first month free and as always i
want to thank bluechu for sponsoring the
joint i want to thank bluechu
i want to thank upstart i want to thank
cbd lion
i want to thank
draftkings again
a dollar wins you a hundred when you bet
on the pacquiao ogres fight if a punch
lands come on guys i'm throwing a
hundred dollars worth of credits your
way
and that's what i do here i want to
thank everybody who sponsored i want to
thank everybody who watched
everybody who supported us i love you
guys with all my heart we'll be back
monday morning ready to rock have a
great weekend
and be tip top magoo and use blue chew
get your [__] hammer sucked
i love you [__] stay black
you